vegas is a little more wild than usual
this week the 2021 pro bowl riders world
championship is here and rocky is live
outside with some special guests to get
all the details hey rocky whoa okay
sorry jillian besides lj our pro bull
rider and call me captain our bull we
also have flies so you'll see me
swatting a lot but first things first
he's been getting a little aggressive in
there so i feel like it's time to feed
him let's see how this goes what's the
technique here what do they eat they eat
hay they eat grain right now you just
want the hay out of your hands and
there we go he didn't eat my notes so
that's good that's good all right so lj
let's talk about call me captain who is
he introduce us to the bull uh call me
captain's a five-year-old pbr bucking
well the pbr is known for having the
best of the best and with that being
said we obviously have the greatest bull
riders in in the world but to have them
great rides you got to have great great
athletes on the bull side of it so
you know he's a
these bulls are taken
just like pro athletes i mean they're on
supplements they're getting fed twice a
day they're
they're they're an athlete and we try to
have them the best they can be yeah you
were telling me that bull riding is a
two athlete sport and that's because the
bulls are treated just like the athletes
you guys are both super athletes yeah
this weekend we're going to pay a
million dollars to the world champion
bull rider and and uh there's 10 bulls
that are going for buck and bull a year
also so
it's an exciting race on both ends you
know we have fans that are fans of the
riders and we got fans that are fans of
the bulls more more than a rider so
it's just kind of whatever you like and
it's really neat to see that see the
bulls grow up and
just perform here on the biggest stage
in bull riding
and what's the scoring like i know
because the bulls also get scored during
pbr yeah and in every ride it's it's one
to fifty points uh one to twenty five
for the bull and one to twenty five is
for the rider you know obviously a
perfect score would be a hundred fifty
and fifty but uh we we actually broke
the the record this year and uh it was
96 and three quarters
so hopefully
hopefully we'll see that again with the
world reigning world champion and that
same bull will be here going up for his
world title also that is exciting okay
and tell me what is the atmosphere like
at pbr and why should people come down
and join oh it's uh it's it's fun-filled
family entertainment you're gonna be on
the edge of your seat the whole time you
know not only is it bull riding you got
concerts and you're gonna have big pyro
and lights and
like i said a lot of energy is gonna
going to be out there because we're
giving away you know millions of dollars
this weekend that is incredible and of
course you got to dress the part too i
got my flannel on you got your cowboy
hat on so it's fun to get dressed up and
hang out with the entire family how can
people get tickets they can get them at
the box office or at pbr.com
wednesday through sunday sunday is going
to be the exciting day where they give
out all the money and all the prizes all
right we are ready to check it in check
it out excuse me i will send it back to
you guys